INFORMATIVE.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Tucker: POLITICIANS TURNED
OUT IN LARGE NUMBERS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WALKED OUT OF SCHOOLS.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
PROSTRATED HIMSELF LITERALLY
WHILE JOINING IN CHANCE FROM
LATIN AMERICAN REVOLUTIONARIES.
[CHANTING]
>> Tucker: THAT WAS NOT THE
CNN ANCHOR.
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS
PARTICIPATED AS WELL.
>> DEMANDING WE HAVE THE COURAGE
TO TAKE DOWN THE NRA, THE PATH
HAVING BEEN GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION IS WHAT THE MARKET
PEOPLE WANT.
THESE ARE BEAUTIFUL YOUNG
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SANDERS AND CUOMO
ATTENDED THESE RALLIES, BUT THEY
DIDN'T GO ALONE.
THEY WERE ESCORTED BY BODYGUARDS
PAID BY YOU WHO WANT TO PROTECT
THEM.
THOSE BODYGUARDS WERE ARMED OF
COURSE WITH GUNS.
MOST BODYGUARDS LIKE TO CARRY
TEN ROUNDS IN THEIR MAGAZINES.
IF YOU WANT TO PROTECT YOURSELF
IN THE SAME WAY IN NEW YORK,
YOU'D BE THROWN IN PRISON AND
SOME PEOPLE OF COURSE ALREADY
HAVE BEEN.
THERE IS NO AMBIGUITY HERE.
AND REPUBLICAN WERE SUPPOSED TO
LIMIT ONE, THE RULERS CANNOT
HOLD THEMSELVES TO STANDARDS
DIFFERENT FROM THE RULES.
THEY'RE NOT NOBLES, THEIR
CITIZENS JUST LIKE YOU AND ME.
YOU CAN'T SURROUND YOURSELF WITH
AN ARMED REVENUE AND TELL US WE